when you went to look for the rights for
this story what was it like when you
found out that of all people Robert
Zemeckis had it because anyone could
have had them and you wound up with an
Academy Award winning director no well I
was I wasn't surprised because you know
obviously it was right up his alley
after talking to him about it I realized
that his take on it was very special and
I and when I wanted to pursue the rights
and to figure out what what else you
could do with this documentary he seemed
like perfect person to do it because you
didn't want to just retell the
documentary and and his idea was to
expand especially the fantasy world of
Mark Cogan camp and tried to delve into
that a little bit and and make it you
know make it come to life speaking of
that element of it is this your first
time doing performance capture yes
was there any 101 or early tips to kind
of ease you into it he did well Robert
yeah he Bob Robert you know Bob my
friend pops him back I feel like I need
to know this how should I refer to him I
always wonder I guess you'd call him Bob
mr. Zemeckis and if he looks at me funny
I'll say Steve told me to call Bob he's
very unassuming um yeah he would say
just he and he said some people hate it
and some people love it because you're
just in this huge empty room and you're
imagining everything and there are
cameras sensors picking up every
movement and he said think of it as
really low-rent black box theater you
know no props no no stage per se just
some platforms and it's all in your
imagination I thought that's a really
good piece of advice and then how do you
take this character into the live-action
realm as well because I was watching
some of the b-roll and you could hear
some of the audio of the two of you
working together and his direction seems
so specific does that come with this
territory of having the live-action
stuff playing into all the performance
capture I think so yeah because he
envisioned all of it very specifically
actually we had a table read which I
thought was gonna be a table read it
wasn't he read us the script and he read
all of the stage directions
and would pause and explain everything
that was going on in the movie because
he just wanted us to see what his vision
was he's very very very specific and how
it goes from live action into this
fantasy world there are our segues that
needed to be very precise both in terms
of camera in terms of performance so how
about just handling all the the dolls
and also the town of Marwan too because
I'm busy reading the press notes and it
just seems like so much time energy
resources go into making that so from
the performance perspective are you
afraid of breaking anything or not being
natural with it well they said you know
there were doll handlers there were
people who were specifically designated
to pose the dolls to help us articulate
the dolls in certain way because Mark
Hogan camp is very good at it you know
he creates this world and he's able to
pose the dolls and hurry in ways that
exude a lot of emotion in his
photographs so so I had to learn sort of
a learning curve because I haven't
played with GI Joes in a long long time
and what I did it wasn't like it wasn't
artful but yeah I got used to it I don't
you know you I broke off a couple arms
and legs here and there along the way
you know you twist the head a little too
far hops off it's just been there at one
point in our life for sure
you